japanese street and festival food and
did you know matsuri the food truck
behind us
actually means festival in japanese i
had no idea
but obviously that's what we're all
about and tell everybody how
why your food is so unique so we're
bringing a
overlooked style of japanese cuisine to
the valley
um we're doing authentic traditional
style street festival food that's not
typically found in sushi ramen curry
restaurants here in town so
my favorite japanese food is definitely
sushi so when i came here and i saw all
these colors and textures and smells
i was already hooked so let's talk about
each dish here okay so this one is our
signature
dish it's a japanese chimichanga
typically comes in a burrito but
we do as a bowl as well ferkaki rice
sesame slaw shrimp chicken or tofu if
you're vegan
spicy mayo and a firecracker sauce on
top oh firecracker sauce i'm gonna have
to stay away from that one so let's get
to this one what's this this one is the
okonomiyaki
it's a like savory pancake basically all
the veggies are mixed inside with this
one and it's topped with yakisoba
noodles
we do a fusion of osaka and hiroshima
style oh my gosh can you guys
see that oh you have to okay you have to
find this truck and
because you need to taste this okay i'm
going to bring it over to joseph here
your husband
also a vet thank you for your service
let's talk about these dishes
okay so first off here we got our
taiyaki it's one of our most popular
desserts that we have on the truck so
it's actually a
waffle batter with red bean inside of it
it's a sweet red bean yeah so if you
like red bean that's definitely for you
um our last dish here is our karage
which is a japanese fried chicken
we marinade for 12 hours ahead of time
and it's a twice fried potato
starch-based
custom seasoned thing it's one of our
most popular dishes on the truck for
sure okay
um can you guys get a close-up of that
look at that
this is delicious okay so obviously the
food is what gets you
reopened and back in business but you
also have a unique story about how
you've been
able to stay afloat as well tell us
about that so actually joe was the one
who suggested that we
went on to twitch which is a live
streaming um
platform and we set up cameras we got an
earpiece microphone
and are able to interact with people
they're able to watch us cook and it's
really helped
build a community and then as well as
like help bring business and generate
for the truck so speaking of speaking of
the twitch community you have
a few people over there so just kind of
tell everybody or maybe
spread some advice to business owners
and to food truck owners out there who
might need to might need a little help
to stay afloat yeah sure like just do
whatever you can to get yourself out
there
um different uh ways i guess routes
basically to try and do whatever you can
right now because
was that a pun pun intended route
all right matsuri food truck tell
everybody how they can find you so we
have instagram
facebook um twitch as well all of our
handles are matsuri lv
and you can find us there um our route
days and stuff will be on instagram as
well
perfect thank you so much brittany
joseph i'm gonna finish this now send it
back to you